hello and welcome to swipe coming up
lasting love on a hotbed of disastrous
dates we take a look at how online
dating has become big business Coutts
technology spell the end of the shark
cull Australian scientists are hoping to
help turn the tide of fatalities
blockbuster brands and indie hits with
about the game's nominations having just
been announced we check out this year's
runners and riders and if you didn't get
any Valentine's Day cards no need to cry
over your value meal for one we've the
antidotes in the sweets games of you
once upon a time dating used to be a
relatively simple process if you like to
go you just had to get your meat to go
up to her perhaps impress her with a few
dance moves then maybe if you are lucky
go halves on a taxi at the end of the
night but things have changed and
nowadays millions of people are finding
the person they click with by clicking
away on line with the creation of dating
apps for smartphones it's become even
easier for people to fall in love at
first tap but has it become even more of
a game Katie Spencer has been finding it
in a psychic city a world of romantic
possibilities at your fingertips
incredible success of smartphone dating
apps is revolutionising how we go about
finding a mate with millions of people
signing up to sites which offer a quick
way of hooking up on sites like tinder
there's no requirement for a detailed
description of your interests simply
swipe right if you like what you see
swipe left if you don't a bit of fun or
is it turning dating into a game because
it is quite easy to get a date food
a dating app you'll go on a you will
meet up for a drink and if you don't
click then you know almost on the way
back home you might you know jump back
on the app and and and start seeing who
else is about the popularity of dating
apps has even stretched as far as Sachi
with one young snowboarder joking that
the number of people using tinder at the
Olympic Village is next level the
immediacy of being able to find a nearby
match is undoubtedly a key factor to the
success of smartphone dating a few end
up in dates and if you end up in
meetings and if you end up in
relationships but I think a lot of the
time it's a bit of fun to have a flick
through and either see someone you might
know or recognize or just laugh together
with your mates and see here you might
you need fancy it can be an addictive
experience the average tinder user logs
onto the site about 11 times a day for
around seven minutes but is it making a
small superficial if you have a fairly
surface and transactional relationship
it's very easy to just move on to the
next one you just go on your app on the
phone find a new one and start again I
think it's changing the way we form our
relationships actually and not
necessarily in a good way the online
dating world is a multi-billion pound
industry a recent survey found one in
five relationships in the UK now starts
on the internet and although an
increasing number of people are using
apps nowadays the traditional matching
websites don't seem to be worried if
they find that the sort of the frivolous
superficial nature of those apps aren't
right for them they'll tend to migrate
to a more traditional dating service
such a paid service life of struggle or
match or eharmony where the
predisposition to meet people is that
much stronger because they're paying for
the service with smartphones an integral
part of most of our lives these days
it's perhaps only natural that sites
which work well with the technology are
experiencing such success whether or not
they're creating a more disposable
approach to dating or simply using
technology to tap into physical
attraction it's a phenomenon that seems
to be transforming how we date Katie
Spencer Sky News
you're watching swype coming up another
reason for rockstar games to celebrate
as the BAFTA games nominations are
revealed but first in Western Australia
there have been massive protests over
the government policy allowing sharks to
be caught and killed the controversial
decision was made because of an
increasing number of attacks in the area
but is a cull the only solution reacting
to the public's concerns researchers are
finding practical solutions to protect
sharks as tom platt no reports catching
that elusive big wave should be all
that's on your mind when you're out on
the water but more often than not the
worry of what's lurking beneath is a
surfers biggest concern even when shark
attacks aren't fatal they leave behind
emotional trauma now managed to get into
Shore and yeah pretty much ya know just
to carry you know seven people have died
from shark attacks in Australia in the
past three years but a controversial
shark cull has been met with protest
reacting to this concern scientists are
developing new surfwear and boards that
mean a great white is less inclined to
take a great bite the whole premise of
our technology relies around the visual
systems of sharks patterns and colors at
different depths that may cause
confusion or even have the ability to
hide the water user it in in the water
column given this fate of increased
shark attacks particularly in in our
part of the world in in southwest
Western Australia you know we've sort of
felt obligated that we should probably
bring this product to market earlier
than what we initially intended to and
in the US researchers have been
developing devices the repel sharks if
they get too close sharks are unique
because of their nose and so we're
really just exploiting that since its
nose is really the thing that defines
the shark sensory capabilities as a
shark let's play with that let's let's
tweak the magnetic fields or electrical
fields and just uniquely repel the
Sharks it can
turn about attacks on beaches I think it
would be a great time now to start
looking at magnetic barriers instead of
just shark nets and seeing if erecting
barriers can keep the Sharks away but
let the other sea life pass in and out
through the nets but even with this wave
of new tech both companies stressed
these products cannot yet be guaranteed
a hundred percent effective for now
without these assurances it's likely
shark attacks and culls will continue
tom platt Sky News you're watching swype
coming up there are snow escaping our
underwater friends as we bring you the
driving goldfish but first now some
fantastic games have come out in the
last year titles which have sold by the
bucketload but it's always interesting
to find out what the critics Pixar and
BAFTA has been announcing its
nominations for this year's games awards
Philip a whole has been taking a look
The Last of Us set in a post-apocalyptic
world not too far in the future leads
the way with ten nominations across
categories including best game and best
story others assigned to the packing
through the latest installment of the
grand theft auto franchise with nine
nominations and the lesser-known
handheld game tearaway developed for the
PlayStation Vita with eight nominations
well here to discuss his favorites and
who could walk away with a prize is
Richard Coggan he's a gaming experts and
also a developer richer thanks very much
for joining us here on swype just talk
me through the game that you think is
really going to walk away with these
nominations grand theft auto 5 is I
think for me heads above all of the
other games out there at the moment I
think it's mostly one of the most
incredible games i've ever played
personally and just in terms of its
technical achievements it's always been
the game to watch as it's grown over the
years and i think of really it's you
know going to completely come into its
own and i think it's a you know he's
fantastic one of your other favorites
you said was tomb raider only three
nominations they so why do you think
that one's going to be one of also one
of this I still won yeah i still believe
it's you know the storytelling of it the
great narrative and taking a kind of
a very old title in a lot of ways and
revamping it and making it very fresh
and very new and taking some of the
elements from it from the original kind
of series and actually making them far
more exciting and I think as well the
kind of slickness of it and it and when
you start playing it you just get
immersed in the actual environment in in
the performer category and in page who
is an actress it is nominated in this
it's it's for me sort of a slightly
unusual category I feel like it's it's
just a transition from films if you look
at all the the writers you know they're
coming from film backgrounds there you
know they write it the stories they're
telling are exactly the same as if they
were for writing for film so it's
exactly the same for the characters that
you know need to be portrayed as well so
any other favorites that you want to
just make sure people are aware of I
think device 6 is a potential I think
it's a really nominations I think that
has yeah I mean it's really interesting
I think it's a kind of forefront of
mobile technology in terms of how they
use in the kind of storytelling through
it as well it's very unusual kind of
gaming a very unusual stole get style of
gaming we're actually turning the mobile
device to move through corridors and
it's actually telling the story by you
having to read through it and find out
clothes Richard thank you very much for
your insight on all those games you're
watching swype coming up we're looking
at love in this week's games of you but
first he has a roundup of anything you
might have missed over the last few days
much to the upset of thousands of fans
flappy birds is dead the smartphone app
that became an internet sensation has
been withdrawn by its creator this is
what he posted on Twitter which doesn't
really tell us much about why the game
was removed from sale it's especially
strange given that it had become one of
the most downloaded mobile games ever
Annie and you know you're onto something
when people start doing parodies of your
idea Sesame Street has launched its own
take in the game called flappy bird
there are close to dilutes how much
control America turns over the internet
Europe's executive body is cold
more transparency and less influence
from the US over the institutions which
control the mechanics of the internet
that's things like assigning web
addresses transatlantic relations are
still pretty delicate following
whistleblower Edward Snowden spying
allegations we want to make sure
everyone has a voice in the debate we
want to identify and solve conflicts of
jurisdiction and we want to officially
anchor internet governance in principles
of freedom Apple has been outlining its
latest efforts to ensure it has an
ethical supply chain and its annual
responsibility progress report the
sourcing of minerals is flagged up as a
new priority it's begun a name and shame
crackdown of suppliers that might be
sourcing minerals from conflict zones
where human rights abuses are taking
place well it certainly hasn't been the
best of weeks to earn bitcoins their
value dropped sharply from 420 pounds to
just over 320 it came after Mount GOx
one of the largest trading exchanges
reported it had found a flaw in the
virtual currencies underlying software
and finally playing a game of fetch with
your pet goldfish might sound like a
bizarre idea but it could just happen
dutch design labs studio deep have come
up with a remote-controlled tank driven
by the fish itself using a camera which
monitors the direction your pet is
swimming in a motor powers the device
and steers it around now if only he
could remember where he's going Lovett's
or hit it it's the time of year when
romances thrust upon us so we called
upon swipes chief heartbreaker Lucy
James to help us out with a spot of
Valentine's Day escapism so where's my
valentine is a reskinning of the hit
disney mobile game where's my water
you have a adorable little alligator
called swampy he lives in the sewers and
just wants to have a shower so you clear
a path and let the water drain into the
pipe so it can go into swampy shower
obviously there are all these obstacles
in the way very physics based game so
you have to hit switches and things
which I'll move the water in one
direction this codec where's my
valentine is as I said it's a reskinning
so everything's been made to look all
adorable and Valentine's II so in the
environment themselves or the rock
formations will be a heart-shaped
everything has a has a lovely pink tinge
and it's a great it's free as well and
it's a very very addictive game Sims has
been going for around 10 years now and
it's kind of the ultimate God game so
that in the sims 3 especially you can
create different characters and you can
control what they look like what they
sound like and you basically control
their life in the Valentine's Day spirit
you can can meet a potential romantic
partner and if you have the the
generations expansion pack you can take
them out on the town for a nice meal if
you work at it and you form a really
strong bond with these sims you can
eventually you know they can become your
boyfriend or girlfriend and you can do
what the sims innocently refers to as
whoo-hooing and then you can move in
together you can get married and have
little seven kids sims 4 is coming out
every q3 q4 later this year they're
really putting an emphasis on how the
sims feel so they'll be able to be
affected by things in their environment
you know if something goes on that they
don't like that you know they'll be
visibly disgusted or you know if so if
they see someone that makes them laugh
they'll be happy and it's quite cute and
it gives his whole other dimension or
two to your little character too bad
Andre this night belonged to ollie
Catherines a little bit of an oddball
choice for Valentine's Day games as it
involves your main character Vincent
Brooks cheating on his girlfriend is
he is in his early 30s and he has a
long-term girlfriend named Catherine
with a cape but she starts getting
broody she starts thinking about
marriage and babies and Vincent gets a
bit scared so he I'm unwittingly starts
an affair with a girl named Katherine
with a see the main part of game play
takes place in vincennes nightmares
where it's a very tricky block-based
puzzler so you're kind of scrambling at
these blocks and trying to avoid things
falling on you you're trying to avoid
spikes coming at you ice there's also
these giant bosses that are sort of the
manifestation of Vincent's darkest fears
so there'll be his girlfriend wearing a
wedding dress at holding a knife in the
daytime you know he can go to the bar
with his friends he can text each one of
the girls because depending on how you
you associate with each one of the girls
changes the outcome of the video game
but yes it's very different choice for
Valentine's Day it's not maybe about a
typical relationship but it is a great
game song with its worth play that's
your lot for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking tech stories
all week on scones for iPad or
smartphone apps and sky news com we'll
see you next time
you